new york city's history is rich and
diverse but in the ever-evolving city
that never sleeps little of old new york
has stood the test of time
so we jumped in the car to go on a
little adventure to check out five of
the oldest establishments in new york
city
on any list of new york city's oldest
and most prestigious restaurants you're
sure to find the legendary del monacos
my name is billy oliva i'm the executive
chef of domonacos the first fine dining
restaurant in the country domonaco's
defined what restaurants are in america
from the 1800s going forward
it's the first restaurant to use
tablecloths printed menus it was also
the first restaurant to hire a woman
you can see our influence on menus
across the country
baked alaska the wedge salad demarco
steak eggs benedict if you see that on
the menu those dishes were invented here
we've been setting trends for 182 years
and we're not slowing down anytime soon
[Music]
on a hunt for sausage links and cured
meats from an old-school butcher in new
york city you could do worse than going
to the iconic charcuterie shallower and
webber
my name is jeremy schaller i'm the third
generation owner shaolin weber was
founded in 1937 by my grandfather it's
part of the legacy of old yorkville in
new york city at sheldon weber we import
an array of german and austrian
specialties like chocolates and cheeses
beers and wines that you really can't
find anywhere else in new york city
the future is based on the past i think
that people are trying to hold on to a
piece of what they envisioned the past
to be and it's one of the only places
where you can still experience that and
that's what will make us stand out
through the test of time
new yorkers walk more than the average
folks so it makes sense that this city
will be home to the greatest shoe repair
of all time
[Music]
my name is joe rocco i'm the third
generation owner of gym shoe repair the
oldest shoe repair in new york city we
have been here 87 years my grandfather
started the business back in 1932 when
he came over from italy we fix anything
here that relates to shoes any problem
you have we can usually fix we do
leather goods bags wallets belts is
crazy
jim's shoe repair is old new york the
way new york was store owners own their
own businesses all families on their own
businesses
people gravitate to us we're here a long
time and we have a good reputation and
we have a passion for the business we
work in makes me feel proud i know we're
doing the right thing by our customers
[Music]
for nearly two centuries ceo bigelow has
cemented itself as a new york city
healthcare staple transporting customers
back to a time and place of personalized
attention
[Music]
my name is ian ginsberg i am the third
generation owner and pharmacist of co
bigelow apothecaries the oldest
apothecary in america we were
established in 1838 we've been here
almost two centuries the building is a
landmark when you step inside the floor
is the original floor the tile floor
with the mosaic the lights used to burn
gas the ceiling is the original canvas
ceiling we're in the business of people
who don't feel well and who have
diseases and we help them manage their
medications
it boils down to doing custom
medications so when people can't swallow
pills we can put it in a liquid form
when they don't like the flavor we can
re-flavor it we're a traditional
business surviving in a modern world
nobody can touch the way we service
people
and lastly we head to one of the oldest
bookstores in new york city among the
high rises of midtown manhattan you'll
find argosy books i'm judith lowery i'm
one of four partners at argosy books in
new york city my partners are all family
members argosy was founded by my father
in the early 1920s we're antiquarian
booksellers we sell books that are used
secondhand and rare
these are books that were published 100
200 even 300 years ago we have first
editions of mark twain oscar wilde
james joyce
walking into the store from a busy 21st
century street it's like walking into
another century
a lot of people
from outside of new york visit once a
year or once every couple of years and
they're always
so happy that we're still here that's a
nice feeling
[Music]
while things in new york city rarely
remain the same it's clear that history
continues to be made every single day
[Music]
[Music]
you